we're not gay I know he saw but um it
wasn't real yeah no you guys definitely
aren't gay nobody's saying you're gay
now dudes a giant muscles are never gay
yeah exactly
okay I'm sorry but maybe I am gay
what no well maybe you are but I'm not
no you guys are just drunk plain gay
chicken
sometimes when I get drunk I go to
Boston Market I eat chicken we're like
the same dudes yeah you're drunk weird
things happen when you're drunk last
week I got drunk I ate the band off my
wristwatch how those be jerky I don't
know I'm just I'm just very confused
about everything right now look you were
drunk you're sober now why don't we get
to the bottom of this just kiss each
other real quick you know and then
you'll probably hate it and we can get
to this proposal cuz I got some ideas
there you go one time little thing
you'll see it was just a fluke and we'll
move on with the day how are you don't
have to or you can just not do that
drunk night totally straight to go let's
go eat some gangster Slim's they're okay
with it there right yeah it's all there
did I go today
what why listen what's going on over
here okay break away break it up right
now now okay and we are back okay so ah
I'm just gonna move on um because I had
a proposal that I was going to give to
you guys and here it is yes let's start
a new rival squad to the Lord's force we
can work out here we can even perform in
the front yard guys okay gentlemen why
don't you guys just go think of a new
name will be here brainstorming what the
hell is going on
oh I'm sorry do you guys mind if I come
back later and I will
oh sorry dude didn't know you're in here
no worries yeah you guys are showering
together to conserve water yep
very considerate what you guys have
monster cooks chicks must love sucking
those congratulations that's awesome
you